[Musique]
en 1994 niss rêve une association qui
porte plutôt bien son nom he puisqu'elle
réalise les rêves des enfants malades
d'enfants atteints de pathologies grave
dont le pronostic vital est parfois
réservé il existe une trentaine de
délégations en France dont celle des
yelin bonsoir Nathalie Barret merci
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation vous
êtes la responsable de cette délégation
des Evelin délégation toute récente vous
venez tout juste de la mettre en place
c'était en en janvier alors l'objectif
de rêver est plutôt simple he donner une
raison de de vivre un espoir aussi pour
tous ces enfants exactement le le but de
l'association c'est de faire réaliser
les rêve à ces enfants qui sont
normalement gravement malades voilà tout
à fait et vous avez connu cette
expérience vous avez fait appel
personnellement par le passé à cette
association tout à fait c'est mon
expérience personnelle qui m'a conduit
donc à demander la présidence de la
délégation des Yvelines parce que mon
fils qui avait une dizaine d'années qui
était donc qui avait une maladie
génétique et qui a été plusieurs
reprises hospitalisé avait un rêve il
était fan de Marc Lawan il voulait le
rencontrer donc j'ai contacté
l'association Rêve il a pu réaliser donc
son vœux et là j'ai vraiment pu
constater les bienfaits avant pendant et
après voil qu'est-ce qui a changé
justement bah avant c'est d'avoir un
projet c'est avoir de se dire avoir un
espoir une envie de se battre pour
quelques chose de se dire que ben j'ai
pas de chance mais là tiens j'ai une
petite lumière qui s'allume je vais
peut-être pouvoir moi aussi bah être
heureux à un moment donné et puis
pendant bah c'est des étoiles he
illuminé c'est vraiment un moment de
bonheur et après c'est des souvenirs qu'
les et qui le garde qui serit mé Mor et
c'est vraiment très très important pour
l'enfant ça l'aide à combattre la
maladie ça l'aide à surmonter les
épreuves et à subir parfois des
traitements très lourds parce qu'il se
dit que finalement il y a un espoir
lorsqu'on veut tout simplement quelque
chose on peut peut-être y arriver en
tout cas on peut se donner les moyens
pour arriver à quelque chose tout à fait
ça ça leur donne espoir confiance en
l'avenir et puis peut-être que ben voilà
la chance va aussi venir un petit peu à
eux et puis c'est aussi la possibilité
dans le chemin de la guérison de faire
un pas et aujourd'hui vous vous engagez
à votre tour pour ces autres enfants
malades tous les enfants malades on va
en parler justement regarde le clip de
promotion de votre association on se
retrouve ensuite sur ce
[Musique]
plateau
on peut offrir à un enfant d'oublier
qu'il est malade rêve l'association qui
réalise les r l'association Rêve
association nationale qui fonctionne
avec une trentaine de délégations dans
différents département nous intéressons
forcément à la délégation des Yvelines
ce soir avec sa présidente nathalie
Barré on disait tout à l'heure vous
venez de mettre en place cette
délégation dans le département cette
phase de mise en place passe forcément
par un moment où il faut se faire
connaître et aller à la rencontre des
différents hôpitaux tout simplement du
département c'est ce que vous faites
actuellement tout à fait donc la
délégation des ivelines elle a
aujourd'hui donc plusieurs axes à
développer un être l'interlocuteur
privilégié donc du personnel soignant
des hôpitaux du département se faire
enfin représenter l'association
nationale et départementale et se et se
faire connaître auprès bah des
collectivités locales de la presse des
entreprise ensuite et ben c'est aussi
d'organiser des manifestations afin de
collecter des fonds pour pouvoir
réaliser les des enfants c'est aussi
organiser des journées récréatives avec
les enfants du département autour
d'activités ludiques sportives ou
culturelles et c'est aussi accompagner
le rêve d'enfant alors c'est pas
toujours évident de se faire connaître
auprès des établissements auprès des
hôpitaux justement parce qu'ils sont
souvent sollicités ben tout à fait donc
déjà les hôpitaux le personnel qui
travaille dans les milieux donc
normalement pédiatrique ou oncologie ou
hématologie sont des gens qui ont un
emploi du temps très très chargé et ont
déjà sont déjà sollicités par beaucoup
d'associations donc c'est vrai que pour
se faire ouvrir la porte c'est un peu
difficile donc ben si les personnels des
hôpitaux soignants nous écoutent et
s'ils ont envie de faire appel
l'association Rêve et Ben qui n'hésite
pas à aller sur le site on a vu quelques
photos d'enfants justement qui ont
réalisé leurs rêves gr grâce à votre
association au niveau national comment
ça fonctionne aussi sur le plan du des
subventions du financement tout
simplement bah alors justement c'est où
les collectivités local ou les
entreprises et puis les manifestations
qu'on organise c'est pour ça qu'on met
en place des événements et
genreévénement il y a des événements qui
sont prévus dès ce weekend tout à fait
alors on va faire le on va célébrer donc
notre premier événement c'est un
marathon Zumba qui a lieu à la salle des
fêtes de jouian Josa c'est donc de 14h à
18h avec trois sessions d'une heure de
Zumba c'est un événement qui est
familial les parents les enfants et
c'est notre premier événement donc on
espère qu'il sera réussi et que vous
serez nombreux à venir nous retrouver à
la salle des fa il y en aura d'autres
aussi à venirut en profiter pour les
mentionner tout fait tout à fait alors
le 9 juin il y il y aura le rando rail
qui se citera à huteuil leeroi par
l'association séent l'air et une partie
des bénéfices donc sera reversé à
l'association Rêve ensuite le 16 juin
donc il y aura la course les héros donc
au parc de saint-clou donc là
effectivement on peut aussi courir sous
pour l'association Rêve soit pour rêve
78 ou l'association Rêve nationale et il
y aura exactement aussi la Journée
nationale des rêves qui s'est programmée
le 12 octobre où là justement on a tout
à monter tout à faire on cherche s des
partenaires donc je lance un appel VO et
des bénévoles aussi éventuellement qui
voudraiit venir vous aid voilà des
bénévoles on a besoin on a besoin de
bras et puis il y a ce site internet au
niveau national rêve avec un S rêve.fr
si vous voulez plus d'information
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner ou à
nous solliciter on vous mettra bien
évidemment en en relation on peut vous
solliciter aussi directement pour
réaliser les rêves de ces enfants
lorsqu'on est un parent un proch et
qu'on a un enfant qui est malade toutit
tout à fait alors comment on est
contacté soit donc par le personnel de
santé soit par les parents qui justement
ben ont connaissance de l'association
par différents médias et qui nous et à
ce moment-là on rencontre les parents et
le but c'est vraiment de réaliser le
rêve de l'enfant uniquement de l'enfant
voilà alors ça peut être aussi bien un
baptême de l'air ça peut être aller
voler avec une montolfière nager avec
les dauphins aller à Disney il y a
aucune il y a aucun coût restrictif dans
le rêve c'est vraiment pouvoir
satisfaire l'envie le vœu de l'enfant
voilà j'en reviens à votre expérience
cette rencontre par exemple avec Marc
Lavoine que vous avez organisé pour pour
votre office justement les artistes s'y
prêtent assez facilement parce que aussi
ils sont sollicités mais comment comment
ils réagissent ah bah après non ils sont
en général généreux voilà et l'échange
se passe plutôt bien avec les enfants et
ça les remplit d'espoir vous nous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure merci donc d'être
venu sur ce plateau pour présenter vos
activités vous reviendrai bien
évidemment à l'occasion pour parler des
différents rendez-vous organisés pour
collecter des fonds il y en a un déjà
dès ce weekend marathon Zumba joui un
Josas dès ce weekend je vous le disais
merci alors qu'à greini dans lesesson
les passagers de la ligne D du RER ont
subi une attaque quasi sans précédent un
collectif d'usagers de car sur la ligne
SaintQuentin en Yveline poissi vient de
voir le jour il dénonce aussi des
violence les
explications car rempli montée houleuse
et agressive sécurité non assurée aux HE
de pointe voici ce que disent endurer
les usagers de la ligne 16 qui reli
Sergi Pontoise à 51 en Yveline un
collectif d'usagers a lancé une pétition
pour alerter le transporteur il a déjà
recueilli plus de 100 signatures en
l'espace d'une semaine quand on a eu
l'idée de préparer une pétition
discutant entre nous plusieurs personnes
nous ont soutenu pour l'ffaire et
lorsqu'on l'a fait et qu'on commence à
passer à discuter aux gens de ce qu'ils
en pensent bah tout de suite on a
quasiment les gens qui veulent signer
participer à cette revendication commune
on est beaucoup d'usagers donc pas assez
de place assise donc bien souvent les
usagers sont obligés de descendre après
c'est la véusité des cars des fuites des
sièges cassés des climes qui ne
fonctionne
plus en cas de panne pour l'avoir vécu
ben on a l'impression qu'il y a pas de
de suivi notamment on a crevé récemment
enfin le car a crevé récemment et et ben
on a continué le trajet avec la roue
crevée de son côté Veolia le
transporteur reconnaît les difficultés
et va adresser des
[Musique]
lieuxle le collectif attend encore plus
de signature avant de remettre la
pétition au transporteur à la fin du
mois